not too long ago someone on Dancing with
the Stars proposed to his partner and
you made this face during the proposal
which is the exact same face I would
make but I guess a lot of women gave you
a hard time for making this job let's
take a look at this is the face you made
while
hi-hi at first of all I have to say I am
with you a thousand percent and I've had
well I think we had it once or twice
we've had people in the audience during
the commercial break here oh thanks a
lot
[Music]
this [ __ ] plane the same feeling
like that's a sacred moment what are you
doing in here for I mean the next week
was finale so maybe some people thought
it was a push to get to the finale no I
just I didn't know what was gonna happen
I thought oh god this is really
emotional I better make this next
question nice and exciting and I felt
like I was getting misty and so I made
an I roll yeah I got so it's like people
were mad right oh we're hissed yeah I
mean I was so that made you I love you
already I love you twice as much just
against people being in love and it's
gross let's just get through life and
get to the grave you know the proposal
that game what's that I'm against the
proposals at games it's like come on do
you have a minute like there's hot dogs
there did you have you proposed it no no
no I know you're talking about
no yeah we proposed I propose to Andi at
a game at the roller derby I said new
yeah
you